was J Robert Oppenheimer plagued by
guilt for his role in creating the
atomic bomb or did he ultimately see
himself as a hero of his scientific
achievements the ending of Oppenheimer
attempts to answer these questions and
many more
there are a number of primary threads
that weave their way through Oppenheimer
first and foremost is the Manhattan
Project but that Arc doesn't begin until
the middle act the first hour primarily
concerns oppenheimer's early years
including the beginning of his time at
UC Berkeley before he's recruited to
build the bomb he becomes involved in a
number of leftist political
organizations these are later held over
his head as both leverage and the weight
with which rival Lewis Strauss attempts
to sink him the rest of the film follows
the development of the A-bomb which sees
Oppenheimer drift ever further from the
morals that once guided him after the
war he seems a shell of his former self
and just made an enemy by his own
government
the Final Act of Oppenheimer truly
starts after the Trinity test every
moment before builds up to the first
A-bomb detonation it's the inescapable
event around which the whole movie
revolves and everything that happens
afterwards is in response to the weapons
creation early on in the construction of
the Lowe's Alamos facility oppenheimer's
close friend and colleague Isador Isaac
Robbie objects to the project of
building a bomb telling him that the
military is only using the scientists as
tools they need us upenheimer tells him
until they don't Robbie replies as soon
as a successful Trinity test is over we
see just how right he was General Leslie
grows who up to this point has been one
of oppenheimer's strongest supporters
quickly brushes him off he promises to
keep the director updated on plans to
use a bomb against Japan but his
Cavalier tone lays Bare The Emptiness in
his words later after the horrific
bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
Oppenheimer makes an appointment with
President Harry S Truman Truman needs to
know what's next what's next in the
meeting with the president Oppenheimer
argues for heavy International
regulation and strict bands on further
weapons yes Truman laughs him off sends
him away and calls him a crybaby
after the end of World War II
Oppenheimer shifts Focus for its final
Act Lewis Strauss becomes a primary
villain of source as it's revealed that
he orchestrated the farcical hearings to
evoke oppenheimer's security clearance
because so much of the film is spent on
the Manhattan Project itself we don't
get as much time developing the
relationship between the two men early
Army CL Strauss caught Oppenheimer to
chair The Institute for advanced study
at Princeton after the war we also see
Oppenheimer embarrass him on several
occasions generally related to his
opposition to the h-bomb of which
shrouds is a huge proponent though his
early efforts to sweep Oppenheimer off
of the political stage are successful
Strauss is later punished when he's
denied a cabinet appointment what's the
purpose of strauss's story in the
largest scope of the film aside from
being the man who made his mission to
destroy Oppenheimer Strauss represents
an opposite kind of historical figure he
wishes to be remembered for his impact
on the world and is obsessed with how
others view him Oppenheimer by contrast
has made famous whether he likes it or
not his actions immortalized him as a
hero to some and a villain to many
others Strauss never leaves a level of
infamy though in a Twisted way he wants
it the security hearings are stripped up
and Heimer of his reputation play an
important role in the film one of the
earliest scenes show Oppenheimer reading
a statement to the assembled review
board even though he knows it won't go
over well as rabi tells him it's a
kangaroo court but Oppenheimer still
fights hard to preserve his name it's
not technically a trial but the effect
is the same and while the US government
puts Oppenheimer on the stand against
accusations of communist sympathizing
and anti-American activity the film puts
him on trial for much larger issues so
how are people today to judge him
perhaps he's right that someone else
inevitably would have built the bomb had
he not but his repeated claims are not
being responsible for how was used ring
Hollow abenheimer tells Truman that he
has blood on his hands and he does quite
a bit in fact during the hearings his
wife Kitty says a history will never
forgive him whether or not he lets
himself be tired and feathered despite
his Progressive political leanings his
support for organized labor and his
persistent pushes to stop nuclear
development after the war Oppenheimer
cannot be cleared of the crimes his work
allowed I don't know if we can be
interested your weapon
the Lewis Strauss plot line ends in
pretty dramatic fashion with his cabinet
nomination officially getting blocked
thanks in part to a vote for my young
John F Kennedy an unnamed political aide
puts a bullet on the Strauss Arc with a
line that calls out the villainous
character's enormous ego after hearing
of his rejection Strauss puts the blame
on Oppenheimer stating that he turned
the scientific Community against him
according to Strauss that all started
when Oppenheimer and Albert Einstein had
a conversation about him by a Ponder
Princeton as the aid points out though
Strauss has no way of knowing that the
new physicist was speaking about him
perhaps He suggests that we're
discussing something more important in
the film's final scene we learned that
Einstein and Oppenheimer were indeed
talking about much larger issues
strauss's self-obsession is reflective
of one of the movie's main ideas that
men who aspire to be great often
disregard the greater ramifications of
their actions there's a distinction
between Einstein and Oppenheimer both of
whom carry a level of intense regret for
their successes and Strauss who only
cares about being on the cover of time
during the final moments of Oppenheimer
we get a glimpse of the physicist
Twilight yes in 1963 he was seen to
Enrico Fermi award from the president of
the United States signifying the
rehabilitation of his National image in
the annals of History still it's a
hollow moment in that conversation by
the pond Einstein predicts that
Oppenheimer will receive an award for
his work however he also says that it
won't really be for Oppenheimer but for
the people who give it to him such as a
reward for Great Men Who yield terrible
consequences Einstein tells him in the
wake of the Hiroshima and Nagasaki
bombings Oppenheimer is plagued by guilt
this is one area where the movie takes a
fair share of creative license with the
real oppenheimer's life we know from his
work that he opposed the use of atomic
weapons after the war as well as the
development of even more deadly weapons
like the hydrogen bomb however it's
impossible to know whether or not he was
truly stricken in the way depicted in
the movie but in Nolan's version
Oppenheimer begins to have horrifying
Visions immediately after the end of the
war his speech to the other scientists
at Lowe's Alamos in which he claims that
his only regret is that the bomb wasn't
finished in time to be used against the
Nazis did happen
[Music]
in the movie this becomes a loaded claim
as Oppenheimer seems far less confident
than the way the weapon was used against
Japan his conviction is likely based on
the necessity of beating Hitler to the
super weapon however without that
concrete enemy he seems lost
dragons Love's Alamo speech Oppenheimer
begins to experience hellish visions of
the end of the world he sees flashes of
white light that mirror the explosion of
the Trinity test followed by grotes as
shots of the skin peeling off of the
assembled scientists outside he sees a
couple carring in fear and a young man
vomiting uncontrollably on the ground
it's a film's way of showing a tiny
portion of the atrocities committed by
the us against Japan imagined through
oppenheimer's perfect knowledge of the
weapon and channeled through his own
corner of the world in the film years
past but the Visions don't stop
Oppenheimer is played by dreams of fire
engulfing the Earth which punctuate
Every Act of the film as a grim
reminders of what he's wrought then at
the very end we get an even more Vivid
vision of the future one that hasn't
actually come to pass chatting with
Einstein by the pond Oppenheimer sees
the intercontinental ballistic missiles
that later grow out of his creation he
imagines himself in the cockpit of an
airplane watching the sky as nuclear
warheads Blaze by overhead a patch of
peaceful study cloud cover is Shattered
by countless Rockets launching from
orbit we see the very atmosphere of the
Earth Catching Fire thankfully this
nightmare hasn't come to pass in the
real world but even in a post-cold war
age the threat remains
in this conversation with Einstein by
the pond Oppenheimer lays bare his
skills the oldest scientist tells him
that he'll spend the rest of his life
grappling with the consequences of his
achievements accomplishment means
nothing when the thing you've
accomplished is a nightmare the movie
seems to say though Oppenheimer
completed everything he sets out to do
at last Alamos the conviction that
initially compels him has turned Hollow
by the time the bomb has Dropped In This
Moment it's easy to reflect on his
earlier scenes his first class taught at
UC Berkeley to only one student stands
out despite a practically empty
classroom Oppenheimer is filled with
excited energy he talks about light
space and his black hole theories he
talks about the magic of quantum physics
and there's a genuine joy in his voice
what would have become of him if he had
instead stayed in that field of study
what if he had continued his labor
organizing and focused solely on quantum
theory leaving the Manhattan Project to
others when he signs on he believes it's
a necessary evil to defeat Germany but
that turns out not to be true by then
though he believes he's too far gone he
can't go back to the classroom in the
same way so he chooses to see his
achievement through to its conclusion
murder us though it may be
throughout this entirety Oppenheimer
keeps coming back to the idea of Shame
reactions it's a core principle that
makes nuclear weapons work and it's a
final note of the final scene while
speaking with Einstein Oppenheimer
recalls making calculations that led him
to believe that an atomic detonation
might set the entire planet on fire
though this proved to be wrong he
believes that they still started a chain
reaction that will destroy the world the
whole movie is filmed like a chain
reaction with fragmented scenes spliced
in between each other constantly rolling
from one thing to the next with no
brakes it's a cascading series of events
that no one viewer or character can stop
after successfully building the bomb
Oppenheimer can't turn back the clock
physics takes over leaving him with the
weight of what he's done now I am become
deaf
the destroyer of worlds in time this
Chain Reaction blows back on him leading
to the security hearings and the
revocation of his government clearance
his wife is forced to hear the ugly
details of his Affairs and though she
stands by him their relationship is
deeply scarred the A-bomb begets the
h-bomb which leads to an ongoing wave of
world-ending weapons
what we're left with at the end of
Oppenheimer is a full portrait of a man
he loves literature language and art is
he a communist according to him only
source of though he opposes fascism on
all fronts and donates to numerous
left-leaning causes he's a father but
not a good one by his own admission he's
an excellent scientist from a certain
angle however he may be the worst of
them all by the end Oppenheimer is fully
aware that he's anything but a hero and
that he may not even be deserving of
pity and yet he knows that history is
anything but concrete Alfred Nobel
created dynamite he reminds us but is
remembered for his contributions to
learning perhaps the most unsettling
thing about Oppenheimer is that we still
don't know what his full Legacy will be